before we dive into the heart of the
subject I want to make a few comments on
the different problem types that show up
in the field of inference you can think
of a general distinction between model
building versus making inferences about
unobserved variables we said a little
earlier that one of the main uses of the
field of inference is to construct
models of certain situations but in many
cases we already have a model on the
other hand there may be variables that
are unknown that are unobserved
variables that are part of the model but
whose values are not known in such cases
we still want to use data to make some
predictions or decisions about those
unobserved variables so model building
might or might not be part of the
problem that we're dealing with to
illustrate the difference between these
two versions of the problem let us think
of a concrete setting you have a
transmitter who is sending a signal call
it s and that signal goes through some
medium it could be just the atmosphere
and what that medium does is that it
attenuates the signal by a certain
factor a and then as the signal travels
it also gets hit by some noise call it W
and what the receiver sees is an
observation X so this situation is
described by this simple equation here
this situation often brings up the
following inference problem we want to
find out what the medium is how do we do
this we send a pilot signal s that is a
signal that we know what it is we
observe X and then using this equation
and knowing that W is random noise
coming from some distribution we try to
make an inference about the variable
so this is an instance of model building
we are trying to make a model of the
medium that's involved but we can also
think of a different problem suppose
that we know what the medium is perhaps
we already went through this particular
phase here but we're sitting at the
receiver and we do not know what has
been sent and we want to find out what s
is so we are looking again at this
equation this time we know a and we're
trying to make inferences about s you
notice that these two versions of the
problem are essentially of the same
mathematical structure we have a linear
equation in one case we know s we want
to find out a in the other case we know
a we want to find out what s is so even
though the interpretation of these two
problems are quite different the
mathematical structure is exactly the
same this is fortunate it means that one
and the same methodology will be
applicable to both types of problems
there is another distinction between
problem types which turns out to be a
little more substantial there are
problems that we call hypothesis testing
problems in those problems the unknown
takes one out of a few possible values
that is we may have a few different
alternative models of the world and
we're trying to figure out which one of
those models is the correct one we are
going to decide in favor of one of the
candidate models and what we want to
achieve is that we make a correct
decision or if not we want to have a
small probability of making an incorrect
decision an example of this kind is the
radar detection problem that we had
discussed in the very beginning of this
course in which we were getting a signal
we were getting a radar reading and the
question was to make an inference
whether the radar is seeing an airplane
or whether an
plane is not present so in hypothesis
testing problems were essentially making
a choice out of a small number of
discrete possible choices instead in
estimation problems the unknown
quantities are more of a numerical type
they could even take continuous values
and what we want to do is to come up
with an estimate of an unknown quantity
that is close to the true but unknown
value of the quantity that we're trying
to estimate so here our performance
objective is in terms of some kind of
distance function we want to be close to
the truth and typically we have a
continuum of possible choices that is
our estimates can be general real
numbers generally speaking these two
types of problems hypothesis testing and
estimation have some significant
differences in the way that they are
treated as we will be seeing next